Speaker 1: So let's try once more attacks.
Sorry, you're back on the air. Let's see if
it will hold and moderators please look into
what's going on. Go ahead. Attack.
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's it's totally fine. Technical
issues happened, right? Yes. Anyway, so basically
my my my issue is it seems to me that a lot
of especially very progressive and very conservative
American media when it comes to foreign policy
analysis seem to fall over themselves trying
to justify the actions of other authoritarian
states. So I mean, you've had for since Tucker
Carlson, you know, making his insane position
about Russia, that actually they're the good
guys and the Ukraine conflict. And I feel
like even on progressive media, you have people
like, you know, Hassan R.B., for instance,
who will say that the US is the aggressor
in the Ukraine crisis. And I'm just wondering
if it just comes to this impulsive idea that
any time the US takes a position, the U.S.
is, by default, a bad actor or if it just
comes from almost a lack of knowledge on this
issue, especially when it comes to issues
like Ukraine, where every realistically speaking
to us held a secondary role and why Ukraine
even came to the situation it is in today.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So we have a very interesting situation
going on here in the U.S., and you're really
getting to it. There are some on the right
that are increasingly defending a authoritarian
states because they're authoritarian and they
like authoritarian states. There are some
on the left that are increasingly defending
authoritarian states, some because they also
like authoritarian states, but others because
they see opposition to those states as promoting
American imperialism. And I am sometimes criticized,
I will say on the show, Maybe you even heard
me say I am against the Chavez Maduro regime
in Venezuela because I am an anti authoritarian
and they are authoritarian, and I give 10
reasons why. And then people will say you
imperialist Yankee encouraging intervention
in Venezuela. And I go away to say, When did
I say that? I didn't say that at all. And
so being against authoritarian is authoritarian
regimes that are putatively left is used as
a proxy to call you an imperialist. So we're
seeing it from both sides for slightly different
reasons.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I agree, and it seems really
weird to me that you will see some people
in progressive circles, you know, justify
the actions of an incredibly right wing, almost
fascistic state like Russia, which has engaged
in incredible oppression of homosexual people,
even minorities. Absolutely. And on the right,
it makes the very little sense to me because
at the same time, you know, the very anti-Muslim
right seems to fall over the heels to praise
Putin. When, for instance, Putin has a literal
Islamist dictatorship in the southern part
of Russia in Chechnya, led by a literal Islamist
who puts gay people in concentration camps?
Absolutely.
Speaker 1: And one of the catchphrases you
have to watch out for is if you levy a critique
on China with the wiggers, Venezuela, Russia,
whatever, and then the reaction you get is
the U.S. also does that stuff that should
be a red flag because it's like, Yes. What
about this? And I criticized the U.S. for
it as well. Right? I mean, it's like I can
criticize both and be against invading Russia
and still think that some of the things they're
doing are horribly authoritarian. The problem
is, a lot of people don't really want to have
that conversation. They just want to say,
you're an imperialist.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I agree, and in many ways,
it feels weird to me because like, you know,
being from Denmark, obviously the media perspective
here is a bit different. Yeah, it seems to
me that there is a general consensus among
left wing and right wing media in Denmark,
even among the more, you know, socialistic
and also more national conservative elements.
Yes, Russia is indeed acting completely out
of turn in the Ukraine crisis, right? And
it seems to me like it almost in the U.S.
has just turned into an other thing where
you can attack whoever is in power currently.
So if Donald Trump were in power, then conservatives
would probably like, Oh, Donald Trump is showing
strength against Russia by talking about sanctions?
Absolutely. Because Biden is in power. It's
just, oh, Biden. He wants to destroy America
by doing sanctions against Russia and destroying
everything. It feels like it's just a part
of this hyperpartisan landscape in American
policy.
Speaker 1: 100 percent 100 percent. Listen,
we're in Denmark, are you?
Speaker 4: I'm in our house.
Speaker 1: Oh, OK, I'm familiar with that.
That's a beautiful, beautiful. It's like a
small city, right?
Speaker 4: Yeah, so our house is actually
the second largest city in Denmark, but that
doesn't say a lot because Denmark isn't exactly
a very populous country. Yes. Yeah, I I study
here, I'm actually originally from northern
Germany. There's a Danish minority in northern
Germany that I'm from. OK, so I moved to.
I moved to Denmark in 2017 to study, and I'm
doing my master's degree currently in European
studies. So obviously European politics is
very interesting to me.
Speaker 1: Got it! Well, listen, I, one of
the places I've enjoyed the most in the world
is Denmark. What's the name of these like
open faced sandwiches that are so popular
Speaker 4: are small blue.
Speaker 1: Yes. Yes, those are delicious,
aren't they?
Speaker 4: Yeah. The funny thing is, so my
mom is actually American and she cannot pronounced
that at all.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I'm not even trying. I don't
think there's even a possibility I could pronounce
it. All right. Attack from from from our hosts.
Denmark really appreciate the call. Thanks
for taking my call, David. All right, there
we go, folks, and that is going to do it for
calls today. We will take more calls and I
hope to hear from you the next time we're
going to take a quick break and be back with
more